un squat comme il en existe des
centaines à fort de france
nous sommes à pons viard à quelques pas
du squat incendie il ya deux jours
la one homme d'une quarantaine d'années
a péri un drame pourtant annoncée par
tous les riverains de pont viard des
années qu'ils préviennent la police sur
la dangerosité de ces squats à l'instar
de ces deux femmes et à la drogue à la
prostitution et tout ça est donc ça se
dégénère qu'on ne tombe pas d'accord
cdg n'est pas ce que ça a plus d'une
fois on a déjà appelé la police pour ça
jean font un peu de n'importe quoi ici
là la police l'a vraiment rien fait moi
je dis bien la pression rien du tout
parce qu'on appelle la police a dit oui
ils vont faire le nécessaire qu'ils ne
viennent pas du tout et c'est quand il a
fallu d'avoir un mot basque à humo et
que la maison a pris feu cas presque mis
en danger
voilà et contentons des informations à
la télé dit on que ces vagues et tout
seul à fort de france
il existera actuellement près de 200
squat il s'agit le plus souvent de
maisons abandonnées occupés par des sdf
des toxicomanes et des prostituées une
situation sur laquelle les autorités
n'ont aucune prise
la mairie ne peut pas intervenir sur une
propriété privée comme cela oui ça
pourrait se faire poursuivre par le
propriétaire qui lui dire je vous ai pas
donné l'autorisation de pénétrer sur mon
bien donc ça va compliquer effectivement
les actions que nous devons entreprendre
ne serait ce que pour sécuriser la
maison ou enlever les personnes qui
l'occupent de manière illégale
un constat d'impuissance qui exaspère
les riverains
à les entendre il y a encore une
trentaine d'années
ce quartier était un havre de paix
notamment grâce au travail acharné du
maire de l'époque quand aimé césaire
était là et je le dis haut et fort
aimé césaire était là le quartier était
autre chose parce qu'il avait du monde
qui venait lui dire bon il ya des choses
qui s'est passé tel endroit tel chaque
espace est un mot doit donc il prenait
des dispositions l'impression qu'il
n'est pas là mais sa présence et sa loi
aujourd'hui la martinique est devenue
l'une des plateformes tournante de la
drogue est donc cette réalité-là change
tout il y avait des gens qui sont dans
les trafics des personnes qui consomment
et donc des personnes qui n'hésitent pas
non plus à passer à l'acte la violence
est devenue plus gratuite est plus
facile aujourd'hui
et puis on a notre problème aussi qu'il
n'existait pas à l'époque c'est le
premier d'armes à feu aujourd'hui vous
avez des armes partout on mène bien des
opérations pour pouvoir les récupérer
mais force est de constater que
malheureusement il ya encore beaucoup
d'armes à feu en circulation ce qui
n'existait pas à l'époque d'aimé césaire
mais je crois que cette réalité-là
change tout selon la mairie de fort de
france ces derniers mois environ 300
squat aurait été fermé et sécurisé des
mesures malheureusement vaine car sans
véritables actions des propriétaires et
seulement des propriétaires toxicomanes
et dit le reprennent très vite
possession des maisons abandonnées